hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
for tonight battle royale is slowly
taking over the world but tips from a
few months ago are no longer viable or
the meta has changed enough for new
tactics you should be aware of so I've
asked as many professional battle royale
players as I can think of to give you 35
pro tips and by asked I mean I've
stalked them and spammed their chat
until they replied these 35 tips should
be good for anyone from beginner to
intermediate and hopefully you guys who
are already battle royale gods may find
one or two things you didn't already
know oh and a quick favor if I may which
skin do you use the most it's Rex right
no just me okay
let's do this if you find yourself stuck
in the storm I'm already sure that you
use the launch pad wherever possible to
escape but also keep in mind those pulse
grenades to push yourself quickly
towards the safe zone in some cases it's
actually more beneficial to grab the
pulse nades over healing items so don't
ignore them they could save your life
most people have noticed that the
altitude your parachute pops at is set
to a certain distance above the ground
or structures what a great deal of
people are missing though is that the
parachute auto deploys at its lowest
altitude if you are away from the island
so places like greasy Grove can be
reached quicker by first jumping away
from the island and sweeping back in
after the umbrella pops this should
allow you to land first and read back
this if you can find a weapon of course
not everyone wants to fight every single
person they see so if you're a covert
player attempt to enter the safe zones
by the smallest side this limits the
number of combatants your face the
theory is simple we are all attracted to
those areas of interest the ones that
are named on the map get the edge by
thinking tactically and entering the
safe zone by the area of least
resistance whether you're a war monger
or a stealth player think about running
towards gunfire in the distance
if you time is right you can sneak up on
an entire squad and completely
obliterate a team which has just
survived a long tough battle it's also a
great idea to get used to the unique
sounds of each weapon if you are
hankering for a scar listen for those
shots and take the weapon by force
let's move on to building building bases
remains an integral part of the later
game combat it's a great recommendation
to throw a trap at the top of your base
to warn off any would be based rushes
but we can take this a step further by
placing traps at the foot of our base
and catch those snooping little buggers
to attempt to hide there by doing this
you also may find yourself being forced
to jump out of your structure and
running away may actually net you
another kill buried by oh and one more
way to use traps on your bases is by
putting them inside a few ways to do
this edit the top of your structure and
watch your foes have fall to their death
or make a door on the bottom and hide
traps behind it there's so many ways to
use traps to Bob deter and outright
murder of the players most people use
brick and metal for those final bases
this makes complete sense as they are
the stronger materials but many people
miss how weak they are during the first
few seconds of the build wood on the
other hand has immediate integrity and
can take the brunt of a shotgun blast
and still stay intact
whereas metal the supposed strongest
structure is smashed to pieces
immediately of course metal is the
strongest material for final towers but
always keep in mind how long they take
to construct trees are the biggest
commodity for materials in for tonight
but at the sight of them falling can
give away your location with big trees
try to keep the last 50 health intact
and move to the next one it's damn hard
to resist I know but no one wants to be
ambushed with their chopper out I'm so
sorry similarly keep your eye on the
horizon line and watch for falling trees
and structures to get one up on the
opposition another thing to consider
with materials in general is what items
give you the most resources or the
quickest resources pallets rock
formations huge pine trees and the
beasts trees at moisty are great to get
out your axe and just smack a few
different things as you walk past you
may find something which yields more
materials than you expect it there's a
small glitch that can be used when
gathering materials ax switching or axe
cancelling if you prefer it works best
on the PC but with practice it's pretty
good on consult
to do it begin to mine like usual but
after your first swing hits switch to
your inventory items and immediately
switch back again and start the process
all over your character will definitely
look like they're having a seizure but
with practice you can obliterate
anything using axe canceling let's look
at our building options during fights
when climbing high it's a good idea to
put a ramp over your head to protect you
from head shots from a higher distance
this is also the case with rubes which
can be placed above your head if the
opposition has the high ground you'd be
surprised how many players jump down and
give away that high ground once they
feel they can't get debris shots
depending on the material you choose to
build with you can peek through the
slots in the structure and get the drop
on your enemy for tonight is very
frustrating in that sense some gaps you
can shoot through some you can not in
here you are completely safe so peek
away a quick reminder about edit mode
edit your structures in particular the
walls and remove all the segments in
front of you you'll now be able to see
through to the other side and it acts
like a one-way mirror
speaking of editing tiles in Sniper
battles most people are looking for
someone to peek their head out of the
top mix it up a little by quickly
editing in a window and surprising those
motherfucks another good tactic is to
hit a wall a few times to see through
the top layer the downside is the
integrity of the wall is reduced but you
can then see through and not have to put
your head above the parapet by hitting
their base a few times - you can also
see when they are healing and plan the
perfect time to strike if you find
yourself under a great deal of pressure
and you're building walls like there's
no tomorrow keep moving your character
around the occasional bullet will get
through so don't stay in one place too
long
when landing in a building at the start
of the game you may have someone
downstairs a cult if I saw over on
Twitch involved stone covers stone
offers limited visibility and build
quite fast compared to metal when in the
upstairs of a house placed down a floor
over the stairs now stand and be ready
to kill your foe by editing out the
tiles once they switch to their pickaxe
edit down and show them no remorse
be aware though not everyone falls for
it so be ready
how many times have you built a sky
bridge and had it shot from beneath you
if you're running with a squad try to
attach the ramp or bridge to other
structures like cliff edges by doing
this if someone shoots out one of the
panel's you and your squad won't fall to
their death
connecting structures to solid objects
acts like a point of contact keeping
gravity at bay when building structures
remember that you'll take fall damage
jumping from a height above three and a
half tiles that's why the majority of
towers you see our are three walls high
if you do fall from a considerable
height try to spam the ramp tile in the
hopes of negating any fall damage as an
extension to this if you're trying to
make an impossible jump use the roof
tile to bridge the gap I get into salty
springs the exact same way every time
leaping from the cliff edge and placing
down a tile to stop my impending death
on two guns and silenced weapons in
particular these are so underutilized if
you don't want to murder people with
them use them for checking bushes or
knocking down trees and walls without
giving away your position in ranged
fights use a sniper or other long-range
weapon to hugely weaken your enemy
whether you hit or miss immediately
switch to your rifle and finish the
fight too many of us me included have
the urge to keep looking down our bolts
sniper sites and admiring our shots but
by switching to another weapon
immediately you could end the fight much
quicker this should be an obvious one
but I've neglected it for so long but
you really should pop a ramp when
fighting the additional cover and
heights will always give you the edge in
battle oh did you know that sniper
rifles can snipe through some cracks in
structures for example those hooks you
see dust around the world
have you ever looted your kill and
accidentally picked up too many bandages
or grenades which take up two slots in
your inventory switching to your axe
while looting will stop you from getting
too many materials it will max out on
its own a few months ago I suggested
hiding unwanted loot under pyramids well
I have a new tactic for this season
placing a lovely structure and door
around the loot here's the theory whilst
raising a team a top chug chugging we
all tend to build a mini for
around us to keep us safe and then we
create a door when we get out well as
these mini thoughts are so inviting to
other players place a trap behind the
blind side of the door and anyone who
can't resist a little look-see will be
obliterated
how often do you use the campfires did
you know that the effects of those
campfires can stack so standing between
two or more will see you heal super
quickly we're giving its night at any
second now our heads are going to be
blown off a few general tips to end on
keep weapons in the same slot where
possible this will improve your muscle
memory and your reaction times firstly
my assault rifle goes in slot 1 with a
short-range weapon in - and a sniper in
5 this way I can stay with my preferred
assault rifle and quickly switch to
either sniper or shotgun in one single
click on console if you always keep the
same weapon in the same slots you'll
never be forced to look at your loadout
whilst fighting here's the biggest thing
of all and it seems a bit of a cop-out
but it needs to be said check those
patch notes things change so fast in
fortnight that the guns you love get
slightly nerfed all those guns that you
hate suddenly become the new meta all
major updates will be covered here on
PlayStation grenade so I'm happy to keep
you up to date with everything for
tonight related and to finish here's a
few tricks for console players I made a
more in-depth video about this so here's
a quick overview by changing the pyramid
structure to a ramp you are able to
minimize the number of clicks needed to
build use the console aim assist to
check for bushwah keys if the reticle
stops for a millisecond over a bush you
know they're lurking there buttons can
be reassigned on console too so maybe
you want to move jump to the thumbstick
so you can battle better in shotgun
fights or you can even change the fire
button from the triggers back to r1 oh
we did it 35 tips from those pros over
on Twitch so thank you to decode to CD
and the third ninja myth or the list
goes on forever there are so many great
fortnight players out there I'm Adam
from Playstation grenade I may be a noob
but I know how to learn it's been a
pleasure
I see
[Applause]
[Laughter]